what if we never invented this plastic
once a revolutionary invention it's now
filling up her oceans and killing
thousands of whales birds turtles just
how much plastic do we have around us
would our life be less comfortable
without it how many animal species could
we save by getting rid of plastic debris
this is what if and here's what would
happen if plastic was never invented
your plastic bag is actually chemically
processed natural gas or oil you can
tear it or burn it or throw it away when
you're done with it but it won't
decompose the way this loaf of bread
will since the 1950s we've created 6.3
billion tons of plastic 9 percent of it
we've recycled another 12 percent
incinerated that leaves us with four
point nine billion tons of plastic waste
if we could gather it all in one place
this plastic mountain would be bigger
than Mount Everest a lot of this waste
ends up in the sea killing marine
animals who mistake this indigestible
synthetic for food if we eliminated
plastic from our lives we'd save
hundreds of marine species from
entanglement and plastic ingestion but
what about us
what would our routine be like without
plastic how much do we depend on plastic
anyway even if you avoided using plastic
containers to bring your lunch to work
or bagged your groceries with reusable
shopping bags you'd still be a far cry
from going absolutely plastic free
plastic is everywhere aluminum cans are
lined with plastic resin without it your
Cola would corrode it within three days
paper cups hide a thin layer of plastic
- how do you think they keep the liquid
inside no plastic would also mean no tea
bags since they're heat sealed with
polyethylene
without plastic grocery shopping would
look very different our liquids would
come in glass bottles our meats and
cheese would be wrapped in paper you
pack all your groceries in paper bags or
cardboard boxes one of the main benefits
of plastic packaging is that it keeps
feed fresh longer without this basic
method of food preservation a lot of our
food would need to be raised or grown
locally and much of it would only be
available seasonally organic waste would
fill up the landfills and become our
main environmental concern our clothing
would be limited to natural fibers no
polyester socks nylon dresses or acrylic
sweaters say goodbye to your fleece
jacket heat and water-resistant safety
wear wouldn't exist either without the
plastic needed for electrical insulation
there would be no inexpensive circuits
to build your phone or computer even
early electronics in the 1910s used one
of the first plastics bakelite without
any plastic we'd be stuck in 1870 still
using non durable and hazardous lacquer
and rubber to insulate our wires all the
progress we've made with affordable
electronics would never have happened
but at least we wouldn't be polluting
the earth with disposable coffee cups
water bottles toothbrushes and other
plastics South and 700 marine species
wouldn't be affected by plastic debris
if the thought of someone taking your
plastic away doesn't ruin your day
consider moving to Kenya or Bangladesh
where it's illegal to use plastic bags
and you might consider getting some of
these slimy pets 6000 wax worms can eat
up a plastic bag in just one hour
[Music]